omics Logic transcriptomics for
biomedical data analysis is an online
training program for students
researchers and clinicians I would like
to take you through the key highlights
of the program that has been designed to
equip participants like you with the
Knowledge and Skills to extract
meaningful insights from gene expression
data
the training program aims to equip
participants with both theoretical
knowledge and practical skills to
extract meaningful insights from gene
expression data through Hands-On
sessions using various project data sets
participants will learn about analytical
methods and application topics we have
structured the curriculum meticulously
ensuring the seamless progression from
the very Basics to the advanced topics
one of the major challenges in rna-seq
analysis is related to accurate
reproducible and effective processing of
large-scale data sets that represents
gigabytes or even terabytes of data such
large quantities prevent many to gain
practical Hands-On feel for rnse
whether you are a big dog eager to learn
the fundamentals or an experienced
researcher looking to enhance your
skills our program caters all the levels
of expertise all three levels comes with
different access types about which you
can learn more on the program page now
let's dive into the details of our
curriculum and explore the fascinating
topics that awaits you in this
transformative training program
to begin with the beginner level it
starts with an introduction to Next
Generation sequencing and covers the
principles behind it and its
applications
participants will learn about the
sources for transforming data extraction
and gene expression quantification
techniques they will also be introduced
to expiratory data analysis techniques
and downstream data analysis through
differential expression and biological
interpretation
and functional analysis through pathway
annotation and a range of analytical
tools to apply to your own research by
the end of the beginner level you will
have a good understanding of key
Concepts and techniques used in
transcriptomic data analysis
the intermediate level covers techniques
such as pathway annotation Network
visualization and regression analysis
participants will learn about machine
learning techniques for unsupervised
unsupervised analysis of rnse data
including clustering and classification
methods this level of program aims to
equip participants with a range of
analytical tools to make sense of
complex transcriptomic data and
interpret their findings effectively
the advanced level covers the use of R
and Python programming languages and
biominformatics tools for processing and
analyzing RNA sync data participants
will learn data in both quality control
normalization exploratory data analysis
statistical analysis differential gene
expression analysis pathway annotation
and machine learning techniques using
computational languages like R and
python the training also covers single
cell transcriptomic data analysis and a
Capstone project which requires a
literature review research proposal and
a presentation the training aims to
equip participants with the necessary
Knowledge and Skills for Effective rnsc
data analysis and result interpretation
the program comes with online mint
guided training and research experience
Venture and subject matter expert videos
live bioinformatics and technical
support and access to team biome info
platform for Hands-On practical
experience it integrates open source
Alternatives as well including popular
scientific tools and algorithms to learn
the analysis
it also includes practical quizzes and
created assignments and a certification
would be provided upon successful
completion
now that you have seen the incredible
value our training program offers I
encourage you to take the next step and
enroll today by joining our program you
will gain access to a wealth of
knowledge Hands-On tutorials expert
support and a community of flying-finded
individuals passionate about
transcriptomic data analysis
to enroll simply visit our program page
where you'll find detailed information
about the curriculum levels and the
Capstone project remember this training
program is designed for all levels from
begnos to Advanced Learners so whether
you are just starting out or looking to
enhance your existing expertise we have
tailored content to meet your needs so
don't miss out on this opportunity to
expand your transcriptomic data analysis
skills and make significant strides in
your research enroll today and let's
unlock the power of transcriptomic data
together